長老ちょっと大丈夫ですか
信ずるってことをテーラワーダと今度は大乗仏教
大乗仏教になると信・信を持っていいらしいですが
一心不乱に信を持っていいことをいろいろながありますけど
大乗仏教では信っていうのがですね
非常に重要視される もう一つ
キリスト教でも同じこと
神を信ずる あなたは神を信じますか？信ずるってのは非常に重要に言われることですが
それでありながら信というのは何なのかよくわからない
でおっしゃっているそのローマ法王はキリスト教
神を信じているか 信という言葉も今までですね
その大乗仏教系の中でもよくわからない
その信っていうのは その正体は何なの？ うんうんうん
いい質問ですよ だからこの神様を信じてる人々の行動を我々のいい加減な思考で見ると
信じてないっていうことになっちゃうんですね
だからそちらはもともと大きな問題があるんです
証拠がないが故に信じるんですよ
だから証拠ないんだから
どうしてもともとやばいんですよ
曖昧なんですよ  例えば長老が言われるヴィパッサナーあるいはサマタです
そういうことの道を通っていくと
必ずそこへある境地に至る
必ずそこへ至る これは科学である
みんなそうであるという
そこに達していないけれど
長老の言葉を信用してそれを実行する
それは それは信と捉えていいんでしょうか
それは試してみてくださいというんだから
他宗教の信とは違うんですね
こちらの態度はもっとでかいんですよ
嘘かないか では試してみたらと
そちらにあるのは確信なんです
そこで仏教では信という単語はありますよ
信は確信ということなんです
確信は種類なんですよ
例えば科学的な実験するして証拠を出す前に論理的に調べてまず確信するんですよ
ああ これはこうなるんだよと
本当かと調べてみましょう
って次のステップなんです
それでデータが出たら
あ そうでしたと だから挑戦する前にこれでいいのかということはちょっと調べてみないとね
最初に だからそういう二つの段階の信なんですね
一番目も論理的にもう一応確信はする
確信してから確かめる
普通科学世界でやっているやり方と同じなんですね
だから信 他宗教の信仰の場合は証拠ないんだから信じなさいということなんです
例えば神がいるということには
もうどうしようもないんだと
それが あなた方には神がいるかないか調べることできんよと
何考えてるのかと これは絶対でしょうにと
初めからいるでしょうにと
神に創造されたあなた方はね
神を把握するということはありえないんだと
信じてみれば全て分かりますよと
だから元々証拠ないんだから
どんな信仰も曖昧なんです
それを知っているんだから
私は堂々と馬鹿にするんですよ
私は知ってます いくらなんでもあなた方にはもう徹底的に信じることはできませんよと
大乗仏教では信心題眼で信を持ってで苦しみの海を渡るとありますけれども
それはそういうことがあるんでしょうか
わかりませんけどね 大乗仏教のことはね
そんなに明確にはね まあ私から見れば他の宗教とそれほど差がないんですけどね
全て信仰 信仰でいくんじゃないかなと
でも 大乗のお坊さんたちの説法する場合は
それなりにもいろいろ物事を調べたり
世の中のことを調べたりして
普通には喋ってますしね
ある意味ではあれでしょうが
その我々のこのエゴですね
エゴの塊ですよね そういうあれを全部そういう何かもっと大きな高いものに捧げ切るというか
預けるというのか 頼り切るというのか
そういう時になんか我々の考えられない境地っていうのが出るのか
出ない出ない出ない そんなのありえないんです
そんな偉いものはいないんです
その宇宙の中で 人に頼ったら
もう誰に頼ってもろくなことないんです
仏法僧に帰依しなさいと言っているのは
そこを人を守ってあげるためなんです
そういうのはもうない
いたっておかしいでしょう
例えばそういうすごい存在にすごい力にあって身を任した方がすべてわかるんだよと
なんで殺すんですかね
それだったらすごい力だから
とても簡単に接触できるはずでしょ？なんですごい
もう頭イカれない限りは
そういう接触コンタクトできないんですかね
これ 偉大なる力に接触している人はみんな頭イカれてるでしょ
結局は  万物は宇宙の中で生かされてますから
我々が苦しむのはそれに反する生活をしているんじゃないか
わかりません 法則とか法
生命ということは法則に反するっていう意味なんです
私はよく言ってる 立ってることでも反しています
普通は肉体で立てないはずなんです
歩くことも物理法則に反しているんです
生命としてやっていることは全部もう法則に反することなんですよ
法則に従ったって言ったら生きてないってことになります
例えば石とかね 建物とかは自然法則に従っていますよ
苦しみもないのは当たり前なんです
生きてもないんです ご飯食べるっていうことは
自然法則に反しています
外から物質を強引に入れて
自分の物質を同じ形で保とうとする
それってありえないんです
物質だったら壊れるんであって
自分の姿を保とうとはしないんです
そんな力がないんです
例えば酸素を取るのは人間だけじゃないんです
鉄も取りますよ しかし
鉄が酸素を取ってどうなるのか
自分が壊れるんです 我々は酸素を取ってどうなるのかというと
自分を維持するんです
肉体を物体を だから ある物体
すごい複雑な形の物体作っちゃって
あまりにも複雑だから簡単に壊れる
鉄よりはすごい早い 土よりもすごく早い
この肉体が壊れるっていうことは
なぜかというと このすごい複雑な DNA の合成っていうのはね
すごい複雑だから だからいろんなものを元素をつなげてつなげてつなげてつなげてつなげてつなげてやるんだから
もう簡単に壊れる 例えば活性酸素あっても DNA がもう壊れるでしょ
遺伝子は ちょっとしたことで壊れる
で 酸素がなくなっちゃうと
もう 2 3分持てないんですね
パッと壊れてます ものすごくもろい
ものすごいもろいなのに
よく頑張ってますよ ご飯食べるは
呼吸するは 運動するは
新しい細胞を作るは だから生命っていうのはもう自然に反していますよ
すべての宇宙の法則に
だから心のエネルギーっていうのは並大抵じゃないんです
そうですね 歳の赤ちゃんがね
なんとかして立つでしょ
なんとか捕まって あれで地球に勝ってますよ
この巨大な地球のエネルギーに
それがすごい奇跡的です
だから物質じゃなくて心のエネルギーはすごいよと
しかし 心にも心の法則があります
お釈迦様が文句言ってるのは
この心が自分の法則に何で逆らうのかと
物質法則に逆らうことに何とも言わないんです
それはもうどうしようもないんです
ご飯食べるんです 人間は
ご飯食べても食べてもやがて死ぬっていうことは
物質は壊れる運命だからなんです
でも我々はだからといって黙ってはいません
がんになっちゃうと早く死ぬかもしれませんけど
黙ってはいません がんのところは摘出して
もう抗がん剤でも取ったりして
なんとかして もうもう年で死ぬ人はとにかく年でも頑張ってやるぞと
頑張るんですけど 壊れることは壊れます
物質壊れる運命だからね
しかし 心は全部すごいことをやっていながら
なんで心は心の法則に反しているのかと
例えば幸福になりたいということは心の期待なんです
だったら幸福っていうのは物質で感じるものじゃないんです
それで心の問題なんです
億を持ってる人にも貧乏やと思うこともできますよ
私は金がないなというふうに思うこともできるし
万円しか持ってない人にも結構金があるな今日はと
贅沢してやるぞと思うこともできますよ
物が幸福作るんじゃないんです
心なんです 心は幸福になりたければ幸福になればいいでしょう
歳の子供にもこの巨大な地球に逆らうことはできるんだから
ハイハイする子供も地球の法則に逆らってますよ
地球が物体は動かないようにするんですよ
赤ちゃん動くんだから
地球にはどうすることもできない
地球もそれなりに頑張ってはいるんだけど
でも赤ちゃんはそれなりに逆らってます
だからこれは赤ちゃんだけすごいじゃなくて
ミミズもやってます もっと小さな生命でも動いてますよ
で それぐらい力ある心が自分の法則に逆らっちゃうんだ
例えば幸福になりたいと思いながら
例えば欲を出す 欲を出しちゃうと不幸になるんです
怒りを出す 確実に不幸になるんです
真理をごまかす 確実に失敗する
一番ひどいのは無知なんですよ
だから無知だから欲が出るし
無知だから怒りが出てくるし
無知が一番基本的な法則違反なんです
例えば無常なのに認めないことほど無知があるんですかね
無常を認めないんだから
泣くは悲しむは落ち込むは
永遠の命があると言いながら
おじいさん死んじゃったら困る
母親が死んじゃったら悲しくなる
なんで披露宴みたいなすごい万々歳で誰か死んじゃったらパーティーやらないんですか？永遠に命あるんだったら
よかったよかった 母親が死んじゃって天国に行かれてとか
お釈迦様 なんであんた方早く死なないんでしょうかと
そんな天国あるんだったらと
それ一体か所あるんです
それもこういうケースなんですよ
生贄あったんだからね
ヒンドゥー教で 生贄といっても人間ではなくて
動物をね 牛やら山羊やらね
殺して神様に差し上げると
そしたらこれって何だと
なんで人に生命に苦痛を与えて
あんた方は幸福になると思ってるんでしょうかと
苦痛を与えたらもらうのは苦痛じゃないかと
そしたらあんた方知らないんだよと
この神のために山羊がね
命を落とすんだから 山羊は天国に行くんだよと
山羊の死は無駄になりませんよと
これで神にお供えできますからと
あ そう だったらあんた死んだらどうですかと
なんであんた死なないんですかと
無理こそでしょうに 自分が幸福になるために
かわいそうに山羊を捕まってきて
首を切って 血やら内臓やら燃やして神様に差し上げて
神が喜んで私を天国に連れて行くぞと
自分が死んで生贄になった方がもっと早く喜んで早く自分が行くでしょうに
あるバラモン人が朝早く起きて
太陽が出る前に沐浴するんです
そこでお釈迦様ではなくて
お釈迦様の説法を聞いたメスカイの女の子がいたんです
メスカイだからもう一生メスカイなんですね
カースト制度だから 彼女は水汲まなくちゃいけないんですね
で 彼女も朝早く水を汲みに行ったら
バラモン人がもう起き上げながら
寒いのに川に入っては起き上げて
また出て行って また入ってとかね
だからカースト違う人だから水に入ったらいけませんね
待っていなくちゃいけない
この女の子は腹が立ったでしょうね
このバカのせいで私は遅くなって怒られるんだぞと
それで待っていて まあちょこっと質問したんですね
何なさっているんでしょうかと聞いたら
このカーストの低い人は知るわけないというすごい態度でね
私は沐浴しているんだと
何のため？それで私のすべて過去の罪を流して清らかになるんだと
あ そうですか それで清らかになったらどうなるんですか？と言ったら
我々はね お前らと違ってね
死んでから梵天に行くんだと
あ そうですかね 面白いことを聞きまったと
ということは 先生より先にこの蛙とかね
蛇とかね 魚とかね 天国に行くでしょうね
ずっと水の中にいるんだから
ブッダの話を聞いちゃうと
何の学問もないメスカイってのも喋れませんよ
バラモン者がカンカン怒ったと思いますけどね
あの女の子はバカにして帰っちゃったんです
平気で アホやと それでこの永遠なものあると真面目に信じるんだったら
我々は早く死んだ方がいいでしょうに
で その考え方で暗示かけられて
このテロ 自爆行為が起きてるでしょうに
しかし あの人々の暗示かける人々は一人も自爆しないんです
若者 女たち 本当に子供たちでしょ
だから一番暗示しやすい
人の話聞く 心や汚れていない
アホな連中ぞ構ってやろう
君たちにはもう天国では特別な場所があるんだからね
それは聖書で書いているんだぞと
コーランで書いているんだぞとかね
マーチャヤっていうね
何ですか マーチャヤは
殉教じゃない 何だったっけ
日本語ありますよ 宗教のために死ぬこと
殉教  殉教 殉教者たちにはものすごく特別扱いですよとか
それでみんな何人か道連れに
それで仏教で言うのは
自分で死ぬこともバカバカらしいし
また怒りで憎しんで他の同じ人間に対して宗教は違っても人間でしょうに
何人か殺して死んで天国に来ると思ったら
その計算で言えば もう死ねば死ぬほど天国は近いでしょうに
だから原子爆弾を落としたっていいんじゃないんですかね
その方がいっぱい死ぬんだから
結局言っているのは 原子爆弾を作っている人が先に天国に行くんだという話でしょうに
それはイランとか真面目に考えてますよ
原子爆弾作ろうと 原子爆弾を作らなくても
とにかくもうもう何て言いますか
この放射能をばらまいたっても
だからどちらでも神様を信仰してるんだから
こういう論理的にこの問題解決することはできない
ブッサンマ あのマスコミやらいろんなこんなことやるなと言うんですけど
両方に悪口言っちゃえば
人の宗教を侮辱するんじゃないんだよと
それは品がないんだと
逆にあなた方もね カートゥーン描いたんだから
壊れるんだったらあんた方の宗教もどうってことはないんだよと
両方に行っちゃえばいいで
そこまで知恵がないんですよ
だから問題も忘れちゃったんですけど
余計な話をして で あの
まあ一応あの偉大なる力っていうのはね
まあ一応もう成り立たないんですよ
で そういう力に接近しているんだ
神様とコンタクトしているんだとかいう人々はいるかもしれませんだけど
なんであんただけということを聞きたくなるんです
そんなに偉大なる力が弱いかと
すごい屁理屈でしょうに
巨大な無限大の力があって
私たちはもうすごく苦労しないとコンタクトできないというね
ものすごく修行したり
もうもうあれこれと このちょこっとした神秘体験を得ようとして
どれほどみんな苦労しているのかというと
その神秘体験というよりは
もう頭のからくりでしょうしね
預言者はいるんですけど
一人にもろくな予言できないでしょうに
それでも信じるという
森羅万象を創った俺そうと言っている神様には何の力もないのは何なのかね
ということで やっぱり具体的な物事の場合はすぐ納得いけるし
論理的ですし そこでこの納得いくことが仏教でいう信なんですね
だから我々いうのは 例えばあの悪いことをしたら悪い結果になるんだそうと
だから死んでも不幸になるんで決まってるんで
それは死んでも不幸になってるかどうかはわからないんですね
ではそこを置いておいて
あんた何を悪いことしたら良い結果出てくると思っているのかと
それは否定できんでしょうに
それは実証でしょうね
悪いことに悪い結果 いいことにはいい結果ということは
そういうことやと だったら当たり前で
死後も同じことでしょうに
いえ 死後だけは違いますよと
いえ 言えないでしょうに
死後だけは神を信じればもう天国
永遠の天国やと 他はもう苦労しなくちゃいけないんだそうでは話にならんですね
そういうことで 仏教の信というのは
まあまあ論理的に納得いくことなんです
論理的に納得いったんだからで
自分の問題解決したわけじゃないんです
渇愛 ああなるほど 渇愛でしょうか
わかっても問題は解決してないんです
それで試してみるんです
渇愛さえなければ それだったら楽でしょうというぐらいは
修行に行く前にもう理解した方がやりやすいんです
だからすごい時間かけて説法することの結果何やというと
ただブッダの教えはすごく論理的で信頼できるものであると
なかなか反論は成り立たないんだと
事実を語っているんだというぐらいのところなんです
だからブッダは単純に推測で語ったわけじゃないんです
証拠あって確かめてから語ったんです
そこでお釈迦様が自分の菩薩時代を説明して
アーラーラ仙人とウッダカ仙人に会った時はね
すごいことを語るんですよ
心の世界について 瞑想の世界について
とはお釈迦様が考えたのは
この人々はすごいことを言っている
それもまた理屈を通している
単純で理屈で言っているはずがない
こんなのは 理屈だけで言えるはずもない
何か確かめているぞと
私もやるぞと 自分でも修行してみたんです
見たらアーラーラ仙人が達している精神状態に達したんです
達したら先生のところに行って 「
先生 先生 ずっと説法してると
これこれ言ってるのはこういう経験のことでしょうか」と
先生びっくりしたんですよ 「
その通りや」と 「あんたもその精神状態に達したんですか」と
すごいんですよ もう二人がいるんじゃないかと
経験者が もうあなた私の弟子じゃありませんと
同じでしょうと だからもうこれっきりあんた弟子ではありません
なぜならば あんた知ってること私は知ってるし
私は知ってることあんたは知っているし
だからこの弟子たちに教えてくださいと二人で
ただ お釈迦様がまあこんなぐらいのことでは問題は解決しないということで
次の先生のところに行って
それからあまり先生を立てなかったんですけど
で その私がこんな人間だよと我々にお釈迦様が何で言うのは
何で言うのかというと
お釈迦様が解脱と涅槃について語っているんです
師匠対は聖なる真理だと語っているんですね
論理で語っているんじゃないよと
何か経験があって確かめて語っているんですから
私がやったようにやりなさいということなんです
あんた方も そういうわけで
この説法ではブッダの教えに対して納得いくといくらいのところで
今まで知らなかったことを知って
今まで考えたこともないことを考えるようになりまして
今までやったあらゆるもう思考的な問題も全部全部消えちゃって
それでは我慢してはいけません
我慢じゃなくて満足してはいけませんと
問題はまだ解決していないんだと
本当に生きる苦しみということ
不満ということ 渇愛ということは問題ですと
それは取り除けるまで
消えるまで実験してみなさいということでね
瞑想は実験して確かめることなんです
それで自分がその経験を得たならば
そこで初めて信仰が 確立したっていうことになるんです
納得じゃないんです もう確立するんです
ではまあ時間なるかな
次の偈に行こうかなと思ってたいますけど
まあそこら辺で今日はちょっと終了いたします
では どうもありがとうございます